I'd like to thank you all for being here
this evening
before we start I'd just like to
introduce my colleagues to my left
Cameron mcvitty the Tactical Incident
Commander from West Midlands Ambulance
Service and to my right superintendent
Rich Harris Deputy police Commander for
Sally Hall
I'm first going to outline the West
Midlands fire service response to Babs
Mill Park this afternoon
I'll then hand over to Rich who will
then hand over to Cameron who will give
details of their respective Services
involvement
around 2 40 this afternoon West Midlands
fire service responded with our
ambulance and police colleagues to Babs
Mill Park in solihull
reports from the scene and videos on
social media indicated that a number of
children have been playing on the ice on
a lake and had fallen through the eyes
specialist water rescue teams arrived
worked out where in the lake the
children were and acted assertively to
take control of the scene
when our Firefox has arrived a number of
police officers and members of the
public were in the water trying to reach
and rescue the children
our crews entered the water
swam to the first child
and our specialist trained firefighters
including technical rescue
rescued three further children
the children were bought out of the
water where they received immediate life
support care from firefighters and our
ambulance colleagues
I'd like to recognize the efforts of my
emergency service colleagues and also
members of the public on scene
I'll now hand over to Rich who will give
an update from West Midlands please
doing everybody
superintendent Richard Harris of West
London's police I'm going to outline
Westminster police involvement in this
incident this afternoon
at around 2 34 PM this afternoon Western
called to Babs Mill Park in kingshurst
which is a suburb inside Hill to report
the children had fallen into the lake
officers who were first on the scene
have gone into the lake in an attempt to
rescue them supported by our colleagues
from the fire service and westminers
ambulance service
four children were rescued from the lake
and were subsequently taken to hospital
on behalf of westminist Police I'd like
to say that we understand how
distressing this is for families in the
wider community
and we and the other emergency services
are doing everything we can to support
all those involved
we would ask people not to speculate or
share any video footage at this stage
however we would ask anyone that may
have any information please do get in
touch with us on 101 quoting log number
2264 of the 11th of December I'll now
hand you over to my colleague from the
ambulance service
good evening Cameron mcmittee tax
question service
Ambulance Service were called to Bob's
Mill Park in solihull around 236 earlier
today
five ambulances four paramedic offices
the Hazardous area response team was
sent along to the scene with five
enhanced care teams which is comprised
of doctors and critical care paramedics
our Merit trauma doctor and further
critical care products also attended
from the West Midlands care team
the air ambulance service Critical Care
car and three Critical Care primates
attended for million Midlands air
ambulance
after being rescued the four children
were immediately assessed and actively
treated at the scene by ambulance staff
all four children who were rescued were
taken on blue lights to hospital each
with an enhanced care team traveling in
the back of the ambulance providing
Advanced life support
two were taken to Birmingham Children's
Hospital and two children to heartland's
Hospital in Birmingham all four children
were in a critical condition on their
arrival
thank you
thank you as my colleagues have said we
know that this is an incredibly
difficult evening for many our thoughts
are very much with the families loved
ones and Friends of those involved
now I'd like to invite you to ask any
questions if there are any
how are they
of course there's no critical updates at
this stage showing as stated they were
all in critical condition on arrival
Hospital
what were they suffering from is the
hypothermia
unfortunately the children in the water
were in cardiac arrest and were
receiving Advanced life support on
women's hospital
you know how long they were in the
waterfall
have there been any fatalities
there's no clinical objective stage
unfortunately
there have been reports locally that
there were a number of siblings there
were brothers and sisters is that can
you say anything about that they're from
the same family or a couple of moments
inside we're not going to confirm that
to you we will keep you advised been
interesting about were they boys or
girls
I'm not going to make any comments on on
the children that have taken from me
like it's not ages I've heard they're
all Primary School made and again I'm
not it's a live investigation it's an
ongoing situation I'm not going to
comment on that did anyone go into the
water to try and save them yes it's
officers first arrived on the scene they
went into the lake together with foreign
ambulance colleagues so yes as it was
combined efforts of all officers going
into the lake to try and rescue them any
members of the public I'm not aware of
that can you confirm there's only four
children involved
by this moment of time I'm not going to
make any further comments on that so
I'm not going to make any further
comments on that
particularly that there were the four
children were taken out of the day and
then there was a long period of time
when you're still searching the
collectors though you weren't quite sure
how many children you were looking for
is that is that right so when the fire
service arrived on scene we were made
aware that they were up to six people
potentially within the water so after
rescuing the four children we have
continued search and rescue operations
within the whole of the lake in order to
confirm whether there are any more
within the water what can you tell us
about what they were doing on the lake
were they just playing
we've yet to establish the full
circumstances of the incident that's
taking place this afternoon so it'd be
wrong for me to speculate at this moment
in time
tell me about the challenges
the kinds of issues that you face that
have been any more compatible
temperatures
so those children will receive
Specialist Care at Birmingham Children's
Hospital and heartlands hospital it
would be rather me to comment on their
individual care packages that was period
of time and but what I can say is that
they are in a critical condition and
we'll see Specialist Care at those
destinations
search just likely to continue tonight
of the water
yes we're going to hold the scene
tonight and we'll be police presence
overnight whilst we ensure
that everyone that's
if it's just in case there's anyone else
that might have been involved but we
will be keeping this thing on tonight
and we'll keep you advised with any
further information as the investigation
progresses you're still actively
searching the lake at the moment
so the specialist medical advice that
we've been given on scene is that given
the temperature of the water
given the age of those believed to have
entered the water and also the amount of
time they've been in there that this
would no longer be a search and rescue
operation
so there could still be two
children there but you haven't got a
chance
that is the advice that we've been given
from our colleagues in the ambulance
service so you won't imagine the morning
for mites
we have some specialist equipment which
is on route to the scene with the with
your people so we will continue
throughout the course of the night
okay that one of the First Responders of
police officer was
taken to hospital for treatment there
was in Subway
one of our officers
suffered some mild hypothermia and I'm
pleased to say he's making a full
recovery but yes to go to hospital as a
precaution
Ary
everyone involved in the community
what's your message to the community
tonight in terms of
a safety message about the risks of
these kinds of conditions so I would I'd
like to take this opportunity to
everyone that's watching or listening at
home we know that the weather forecast
for the next few days is expected to be
bitterly cold
please adults and children alike stay
away from open water under no
circumstances Venture onto ice
regardless of how thick or safe you
think this ice may be
can I just ask obviously and the four
children that you you know of I'm
assuming all of their parents and
Guardians are informed
um I'm not alluded to make a comment on
that at this stage and is it is it that
you just think it's possible there may
be more children or do you actually have
evidence that makes you believe that do
you have parents who don't know where
their kids are tonight
at this moment in time we're conducting
searches in the like I can't confirm
that we are looking for anybody else at
this stage but we will continue to
conduct our searches throughout the
course of the night
when can we expect
we should be in a position to give you a
further update following tonight so we
should be in a position to give you
further updates tomorrow tomorrow
morning
yes
okay if I can thank everyone for being
here tonight and for those that are
watching at home as we said earlier we
know that this is an extremely difficult
time for many and the thoughts of all of
the Emergency Services remain with those
families loved ones and Friends of those
that have been involved in this incident
thank you
is
from a police perspective would need to
come back in terms of course there were
a number of different policing teams
that arrived at the scene from a 999
responders to local policing offices
thank you